dude we're back it's wild ride with
stevo
and man this week we are going to learn
about the
highest levels of making money as a
stand-up comedian gosh
darn it gabriel iglesias sells out
arenas everywhere he goes man you're not
even gonna believe
this guy's operation so let's get into
it
ladies and gentlemen gabriel iglesias
yeah yeah i want you to meet my my
co-host scott randolph
what's up dude and coming from off
camera you'll probably hear
paul briskey chime in from here and
there what's going on gabe how are you
good are you on a tour bus i'm trying to
i'm trying i'm looking for
it's uh it's an rv a class b motorhome
built on a dodge ram pro master chassis
and thank you for joining us man what an
honor
i i don't even know where to begin let's
just dive into politics and religion
ah man so um i always feel like i'm
following you like
anytime i go somewhere like stevo was
just here it's always a thing stevo was
just here
like uh i want to say about a year and a
half ago i was in
um what was it toronto or vancouver
somewhere it was for the jail
and i follow you on on your social media
so every time i'm looking at your social
media
you're always naked man you're always
getting naked more than a mexican with
tequila you do
in the group photos that you see uh with
the clubs
no no he's talking about me and lux in
the windows okay
and hey thank you so much man i had no
idea i i started following you too
um and congrats on everything man
[ __ ] a
thank you also uh let me finish so i'm
following your your your uh your stories
and i'm like
there's naked again make it again i'm
like wow look at that view
and what wound up happening is when you
left
i got your room i got your room with
that view
i'm like oh my god this is where that
went down
and then i couldn't sleep on my bed
because i'm like no
there's like a dick print still on the
window
that was in vancouver yeah that's a
really good giveaway for sure
doesn't know to clean that window
because of that
yeah it's extra cleaning yeah for sure
man so i was trying to figure it out
because one of the first questions i
wanted to ask you
was uh do did you tape your special
in a gigantic basketball arena
and or or did you do the whole tour in
arenas
uh the whole tour is in arena so um it's
it's one of those things where we don't
have to change very much as far as the
the uh the flow of the show the show
goes at that pace
but it's not like you know because if
sometimes um
we'll do like a comedy club where the
pace is one thing and then you go from
the club to a theater
and the the the temple the pace is off
you have to actually be
uh performing it whatever it is to get
used to it you know
i have to work at suppressing
my jealousy
when did you graduate to arenas because
that's [ __ ] huge
i want to say it's been arenas now for
probably the last three to four years
and then before that it was a mixture of
of uh theaters and arenas we were kind
of doing that that crossover
and then uh before that i mean i was i
was hardcore comedy club
to the point where i i probably stayed
in the club longer than i should
because i was doing two weeks back to
back like i was doing um
wednesday thursday to friday three
saturday to sunday and then a monday and
then i
do the same thing the following week and
so my manager's like dude
can we just go to a theater because this
is ridiculous i'm like no but we're
right next door to dave and busters
i mean it's crazy and your free nachos
you're wasting because you're working
way too hard man
just go to the theaters and so we were
at the theaters for uh
for a little while and that jump
happened right away with the uh
to go from theater club was a long time
theater was a little bit and then
arena has been the the case since uh
since then what was that jump do you
think that was that like uh doing the
voice
voice over work or like magic mike or or
just because you're killing it so hard
in comedy that people are showing up
i think social media is the is the big
factor because it used to be that
if you did a certain uh talk show that
was your bump
that was your push and then it was like
okay if you did a half hour special or a
one-hour special
but i think that youtube and and just
social media in general has been so
amazing that
um encouraging fans to start posting you
know the videos and
not just the entire special but if you
all you need nowadays is to get
eyeballs on you so if you got a good
three to five minute clip that
that captures people's attention that's
uh that's all you really need and just
having a good um engagement with your
fans
i call it digital grassroots man you get
the people to talk about you and that's
that's all you need uh
get them talking about you you don't you
really need a tv show nowadays you can
you can get everything through uh social
media
yeah it's crazy your youtube's killing
it right you have
how many million subscribers uh it's
between four and five as [ __ ]
dude all right yeah i mean you gotta you
gotta
evolve you gotta learn um and the
the jump from comedy clubs to theaters i
mean that's such a gap i
i was beating my head against the wall
for years you're like [ __ ] man you know
because
with the comedy clubs two shows every
[ __ ] night like staying all weekend
long it's such a grind
and uh i just made the graduation to
theaters
like i got the call one week before the
coronavirus shut everything down
this yeah i think all of us were like
yay
i i was uh one show away from from
performing where uh
michael jordan used to freaking kill it
every night in chicago uh
so we you know we were in kalamazoo
michigan we got the phone call they
pulled us on the bus and they're like
listen
uh yeah that's it that's all folks damn
i'm like it's crazy man but we we uh we
read that you're really enjoying the
quarantine
you know i i it's one of those things
where people are always saying when are
you going to take a break when are you
going to take a vacation what are you
going to take some time for yourself
and you never know i mean this is show
business it could go away
any moment and so i always felt that if
i didn't always keep my hand on it
and keep pushing and going because the
opportunity was there
that it would go away someone else is
going to wind up you know taking the
magic
for sure great of it and when everybody
felt the wrath of corona and the
shutdown was real i i went a little stir
crazy for about three weeks
and then i noticed that i was actually
getting sleep which is something i never
got
i was i mean i'm still averaging now
between eight and ten hours which is
unreal
yeah sleep's important man it's a big
deal
and i i totally know what you mean
because
i've always felt that way you know like
man
the the spotlight is very fleeting
you know and and while i have the
earnings potential i don't want to
you know i don't want to wait until
later and then think oh well [ __ ] man i
should have hustled when i had the
opportunity
so dude i'm the same way man i'm
relentless
hustle and now with the shutdown the
the coronavirus we're just hustling that
much harder
in every other space you know all the
digital [ __ ]
do you do a podcast uh no i haven't and
that's the one thing i just i haven't
done i feel because uh
i'm not as committed every asshole's got
one man
it was hard for me to jump on the
bandwagon but i'm glad i did
you jumped in the bandwagon yeah
uh my fans last week if uh if they would
like for me to go i said i will do a
one-time podcast
you know just try to do one and if
they're into it and
and the fans are like yeah please do and
i'm like so now i'm like okay let me try
to figure it out because i want to make
sure that if i'm only doing one
that i go as all you know all out as
possible with it
um but trying to find a way to make
things work so i
you guys were talking to my buddy uh
before i got on here about uh
merchandising so we've been doing a lot
of merchandising selling this selling
that
uh trying to stay busy and then um i've
been taking on
other projects doing whether it's voice
over work or uh
trying to do um like promos for products
like
i started i started working with a
company to sell an anti-chafing
uh cream nice that's what the hell i'm
doing now i'm selling
anti-chafing cream yeah that's
that's a big deal my buddy preston lacy
he's uh
where your balls are yeah i feel like he
does uh he's always putting talcum
powder
on his balls that's an anti-chafing
thing
and said yes to you chafe a lot gabriel
actually i don't the irony is that a
week after i taped the commercial i i
freaking
you know i was working that treadmill a
little too hard and i had a little
friction burner
yeah i get like that because sometimes i
won't wear any underwear then now
as i get older i'm like [ __ ] i got to
wear underwear because i keep chafing
yeah that's what happened is my
underwear rolled up and then freaking
the you know
yeah for sure you know i think uh
that you've got the evidently a great
team
around you i don't think that it's gonna
be that much work for you
to do a podcast man like i was telling
my guys before we got on
hey guys i want to thank you for making
it so easy for me they set up all the
cameras they set up all the mics
all i got to do is jump in the van and
we're ready to go
and i bet it would be that easy for you
plus you could do it in your vw bus or
something sick
oh yeah a bus at your compound that'd be
sick how many of those sons of [ __ ]
do you have vw buses
way too many man i probably would have
been better off with a cocaine habit but
no
i've got somewhere along the lines of 20
between 20 and 25 buses
do you buy them and then like refurbish
them and sell them or once you got it
you got it for life
uh i haven't sold any of them uh what i
what i did in the beginning was
um i was working with the jay leno's car
guys
uh same guys that work with um seinfeld
and so
they were like hey whatever you need
just let us know and i had no idea they
were that quick
like you give them a specific year color
everything and they just
here you go yeah and then be like oh
shoot sorry i got doggies
anyway that's what i did in the
beginning and then i i met uh someone
who actually does
car restoration but his specialty is
volkswagen
oh wow and he just uh he just
tell me what year what color we'll pimp
it out and
that's how i do the cars now great [ __ ]
dude i bought a 1974
vw bus and the mc i brought it in the
mechanic he's like dude why the [ __ ] did
you buy this
and and i was like i don't know i've
always wanted to drive one
dude every week every [ __ ] week that
thing broke down i'm like scott dude how
are we supposed to get anything [ __ ]
done
when he can't drive anywhere dude i
would be like having like
all i'd be picking up workers to help us
work or something you know and then all
of a sudden like i have to call triple a
get them towed we'd all jump in an uber
and get to go to the house and finish
i mean every [ __ ] time i got in that
car like
my aaa membership just like expired or
you know i used it all up
yeah if you have a volkswagen whether
it's a car bus a thing or
karman ghia uh you're you're gonna have
those days where uh you put your key in
and all you're doing is just
putting your key in yeah they're much
better
in a showroom never driven just parked
there to look at
yeah yeah do you drive them around ever
gabriel i'll take them out but i mean
i'll keep them in the neighborhood i'll
keep them in
the city yeah stay close yeah you're
redoing all the engines and you're still
keeping it in the neighborhood like i
was
i was going everywhere you know that was
my main commuter
yeah if it's a daily driver you got to
really stay on top of it uh
my suggestion because it is a 1974. i'm
having a 1974
right now i'm doing a little conversion
where
i'm having that that engine taken out
and i'm replacing it with a subaru
engine it's gonna have like 180
horsepower which is insane
and it's going to be very dependable uh
daily driver and it's also going to have
air conditioning
[ __ ] so you'd feel confident driving
that thing every day all day
oh yeah yeah that car will be a
completely diff it's not even a
volkswagen as far as i'm concerned it's
you know stop thinking about it like
so you're uh you talk about your son in
in comedy
he really lives with you uh well
technically
well his mom and i are no longer
together so now he uh he works for me so
he's here at the uh the office all day
so i see him a lot more now than ever
i'm watching him be productive so that's
a good thing that's a very good thing
i saw on your specialty here talking
about
how he he watches videos of other people
playing video games
that's uh what is it called as a twitch
i think
yeah twitch yeah streaming whatever i
don't
understand it i always said if i was
gonna have kids
i would rather them smoke pot than play
video games
i just think video games are so
destructive
to uh i may think to life to life
man yeah i think like porn in a
relationship but it's funny these days
people make a career out of it so it's
hard to kind of
say that still like yeah if you can make
money
right but you're damn well not making
money watching other [ __ ] do it
that's true but some people i mean a lot
of people you watch people play
basketball or people watch people play
other games
like what's the difference watching
someone play pac-man or something you
know that was exactly the point in the
special
oh nice there we go yeah
so uh okay man now um
to touring [ __ ] arenas uh
like it's it's just so so creepy what's
the leap like from
theaters to arenas man gabriel iglesias
is a champ
i just so appreciate how open he is
about his business
dealings and i'm going to open up to you
right now
about the most important command i have
for my dog
wendy that command is wendy
it's bedtime that means she gets
right in bed and ready to snuggle with
me you know what
i love my bed because it is a
helix mattress helix
sleep.com you go on there and you fill
out this little
quiz they give a little bit of
information and they tell you
what is the best mattress for you and by
gosh they get it right because this
mattress
is amazing and i want
you to find out how amazing right
you go to helix sleep.com
stevo fill out the quiz figure out what
the mattress is for you and they will
give you up to 200
off on that mattress plus they throw in
two free pillows with every mattress
order
and you'd be crazy not to get that
because these pillows
are off the charts so again
for up to two hundred dollars off any
mattress
and two free pillows go to
helix sleep.com
stevo you're gonna sleep better you're
gonna be more comfortable
you're gonna have a better life now
let's talk about arenas
well let's see the the math is always it
has to be a minimum
of uh 4 000 people in order to make that
jump so like
uh with comedy clubs it's like to make
the jump from a comedy club to a theater
is a little bit easier because on
average if you're selling out
most clubs you can do 300 to 350. so you
figure 300
uh you do four shows that's a theater
show right there
so with the the theaters the theaters
range from a thousand seats
to about 3 3 500
and then like i said 4 000 is that jump
that's where you make that that jump so
if you're able to do two uh two theaters
two big eaters
you're ready for the uh for the arenas
man they're like
when they're talking to me about the
deals and stuff they're like that movie
where um
a beautiful mind or russell crowe he's
just talking and all the
things that's what they do they're like
gabe look at man you're gonna play this
arena this arena and this is going to
happen and the blah blah and the
percentages and that
i'm like ooh how long did it take you to
do two theaters in one night
right away um man i i
honestly i couldn't tell you it's been
so uh so long
um i just know that it always took
someone telling me hey
you need to go from it from here to here
i always felt safer staying
more you know let's just keep it cool
we'll need to go out there and get crazy
we'll need to start you know going out
there and then
gambling if we don't have to i don't
mind playing this small room
multiple times as long as we're not
losing any money and so my
my manager he really gave me that kick
in the butt because i didn't want to do
it
it's so the other way around with us and
i'm thinking here
gabriel just made it sound so simple so
like doable
and uh my agents he's like i don't know
man now you're gonna
go back you're the one pushing for
bigger shows and they're the ones kind
of being like uh maybe
when we get done i'm gonna [ __ ]
probably have to chew out my agent be
like man i just found out theaters
aren't that big of a [ __ ] deal
dude you know we sell out comedy clubs
left and right all the time
what's the [ __ ] problem yeah i think
they're ha i mean i think they're happy
with those just
i mean at the end of the day sometimes i
feel like agents don't give a [ __ ] and
they're just like happy
i think it's easier to book comedy clubs
for the agents
i think that the theater takes a little
more work well i know that with a comedy
club they can always um
the age you can always work for a higher
percentage you know because i think the
standard
you go in there and a few selling
tickets they can get you in a 70 30
split
but then you know you're gonna go in and
grind them and get it to 75 get it to
80.
you know when i left the clubs i was at
95 percent so i'm like
hey [ __ ] dude
that was for them to work with the
promoter and get those deals just right
and so you know they my agent didn't
feel comfortable
with me going to the theaters if the
deals weren't right and if
you know the guarantees they got to make
sure that the guarantees were there and
that was a big thing was making sure
that those guarantees were there but the
promoter has to really believe in you
and trust you
to uh to do your press to go out there
and and deliver a good solid show and to
have that following
man it's badass and it's so impressive
that you're
taking the orders for all of your merch
right there
in-house you're fulfilling all the
orders doing all the shipping
how did you put that together um
a long time ago i started selling cds at
my uh
my comedy club shows i you know i had a
cd burner
the those you know you'd go to uh uh um
what was it circuit city
and you could uh you go to circuit city
and you buy a cd burner and it basically
looked like a vcr with the two little
you know the disc things out there and
and uh i would i would
burn my uh my 40-minute show that i had
recorded at the ice house
and so um i would just sell that bootleg
cd after the show and i'd make a little
bit of extra money
every week and then my buddy martine
goes hey dude um
you know you should sell t-shirts and i
go t-shirts he goes yeah you should sell
t-shirts and i'm like
well look if i sell the cd the cd cost
me
what 70 cents per disc and i turn around
and sell it for 20
i go a t-shirt cost me six dollars to
make and to sell it for 20 i go why
would i the percentage is not there
i'm better off just selling the disc and
he's like trust me you're gonna kill it
with the t-shirts
so uh i tried it one time and the
t-shirts just destroyed
like it was insane how good the t-shirts
did and so now i'm selling a cd
and a t-shirt and then i added a second
t-shirt and the third t-shirt
next thing i knew my whole garage was
full of inventory
and a couple months we grew out of the
garage my girlfriend was pissed
she's like i want my freaking garage
back and uh
because it was insane it looked like an
episode of hoarders
overflowing and so we wound up getting a
warehouse here in long beach
and then uh within the year we had to
get a double wide because it just it
just kept growing
i kept adding more t-shirts next thing
you know i'm adding koozies i'm adding
magnets i'm adding posters
i mean you name it i pretty much have it
i'm like that uh that movie spaceballs
when they go to the merch area
yeah yeah what was the merchandise
gabriel iglesias the flamethrower
dude i love that so much man and my
story's a little bit similar
after every show that we do we turn that
[ __ ] place into a flea market man
we we 100 and and scott here he's my
tour manager
he's my my merch guy my my co-producer
and when we first started working
together i had just gotten out of
this sex addict program right and i'm
trying to like
you know learn how to have a healthy
relationship i can't fool around with
any chicks on the road
so i called up scott and i said hey man
can you come with me
on this trip as my [ __ ] blocker
make sure that i don't [ __ ] around with
any chicks and i was like i sell books
and t-shirts after my show and that can
bring in some revenue for you
so he shows up and he says you only have
books and t-shirts
you don't run credit cards dude he
[ __ ] took over
and now well dude you went from
when i first started working with you
his accounting system was like an
x or a circle around it if one was like
you remember how you used to do that
and then i'm like dude you got to have
spreadsheets and you know just expanding
the product line
now we've got dick pic pens [ __ ]
sunglasses socks multiple posters stevo
sunglasses stevo
socks hot sauce yeah my own brand of hot
sauce dude it's it's pretty insane
let's take the opportunity right now to
plug your
your merch man where are people buying
your merch online
they can go to a fluffyguy.com so fluffy
and then the word guy or just google the
word fluffy and it'll take you directly
to the website
fluffyguy.com you heard it here folks
let's put a spike on gabriel's merch
huh hey gabriel i got a question because
you look so good and you lost 100 pounds
right and so
so i know for me touring and and just
living that like tour life
you know the late night deep fried food
at the comedy club like what was that
transition like for you because
like did you change your rider up when
you're like okay i want to start losing
weight but you're on tour like
um well that whole losing of a hundred
pounds happened a few years ago and
uh i know for a fact that the eating
changed
i had incorporated yoga and weight
training and then
not eating like an [ __ ] as much
and so uh that's that's how i had done
it i know that for a fact that i stopped
eating uh
late at night and that the fried food
cut back a lot and
i stopped eating bread that was the main
thing was bread yeah
we just made it so that um mostly deli
trays
keep it keep it you know high protein
fat so deli trays
make sure there's no bread make sure
there's no crackers so good though
sometimes dude
people will argue all day but hey that
was my way of cutting sugar
plus i'm diabetic so there's a lot of
different things that went into that
and you know when you're selling out
arenas
i think it's it's possible to get a deli
tray
in your green room
what kind of a we've heard about crazy
riders on the road man where people have
to have
a certain kind of brand new sneaker and
like
you know can agree
our rider has always been club soda yeah
we want
club soda like sparkling water and that
was only because i used to come out on
stage smashing cans on my head until
they broke
yeah well for a prop not not necessarily
to drink it
right yeah i used to do that with beer
cans way back in the day
i'd come out and throw out beers into
the crowd break them on my head and then
i got sober so i started breaking cans
of club soda on my head
hurt more the same same difference man
it's just bad for you i used to
like do it until i remember i'd wake up
in the morning and i'd
walk out of bed like diagonal you know
like my balance was off and i was like i
got to stop hitting myself in the head
every night jeez
you think you gave yourself a concussion
doing the whole yeah every night
and it turns out that with the cte thing
that uh
a lot of little hits is um actually they
accumulate more it's
worse i think than just a few big hits
but yeah i've been i've been i had all
that [ __ ] man [ __ ] that
yeah is anything crazy on your rider
gabriel an arena rider
just in case any of you don't know what
a rider is it's a list of things that an
artist demands to have waiting for them
at the venue when they show up for their
performance
and i happen to have a rider of things i
demand to have
in my pocket at all times that's right
in my pocket i always have my raycon
earbuds these things are premium
earbuds and they're half the price of
most
all other premium earbuds plus you know
those other ones
you can't control like stop play skip
track
these ones have a button built in and
they fit
so well right into my ears that
i can actually lay my head on the pillow
and have no problem listening to stuff
what do i like
to listen to man audio books i'm on this
one called
sapiens that's a whole other story it's
insane
but yeah get your get your raycon
earbuds
all right here's how you do it you go to
buy raycon.como
and you get 15 off once again
15 off when you go to buy raycon dot com
slash stevo and you can rock and roll
plus always have it in my pocket ask me
if you see me
now let's hear about gabriel's writer no
like i said and i know that saying deli
tree sounds a little bit like
oh telly tray but it just sounds
impressive it's all it is
here that has cheese and bologna and ham
on it it's not really that's like six
bucks at costco
basic very very basic um all i needed
was
was that um you know like i said a
couple uh six packs of diet soda
and and i was good i don't i didn't
really ask for anything uh crazy
um i did make sure that um if i had
towels
the towels needed to be used pals i
didn't want new towels because
uh when you shower you get your full
lint like
really nice black towels and if you've
ever
tried to use a brand new black towel
after taking a shower man you are just
covered
you were just covered so i needed to
make sure that the towels were were used
which sounds weird
so do you route the tour so that you can
go out on a tour bus
uh yes um like i said my agent managers
everybody works together to basically
grab the map and then
just route it we have a bus and uh we
have semis and everything
so we it's like a little mini wwe setup
where you know that everything's just
going together in city the city and
and basically it'll do like an s across
the u.s we try to stay away from the
east coast as much as possible just
because
we've done the east coast with a tour
bus with semis
in the winter and it sucks
so um the routing now i think we got it
down we just couldn't
we couldn't plan for the corona so that
was the only problem this time
then when you say i we have a tour bus
you bought your own tour bus in semis
[ __ ] hey at least at least the tour
bus for many years
and then finally i just got one and i
loved everything about it
it was basically i was spending more
time there than i was in my own home
and very comfortable with the bed i felt
very comfortable with the bus it was
very dependable
you know i still got my same bus driver
and so it's just one of those things
where
uh it became available and they gave me
a really good deal on it and so i went
for it
um if i would have known that the whole
thing would have gone down i probably
wouldn't have bought it
but for the long haul right now it's
just been sitting
in nashville uh next to brooks and
dunn's bus for
the last five six months man [ __ ] i mean
dude that's how come
we're in this rv right now because we
went out on a europe tour
and and we [ __ ] rented uh
the this bus the last person that had
that [ __ ] bus was justin bieber
and we're on this [ __ ] bus we had the
time of our lives
and uh and then the next thing you know
i just want to always want to be
traveling in some kind of a bus if we're
going to go film something
rent an rv and i was like i gotta have
an rv
did you guys have an uh that double
decker bus we did
yeah beat the street yeah to beat the
street yes that's exactly that's the one
i use too
when i go over there yeah and then we
got in big trouble for for [ __ ] on
it
dude like i walked downstairs and like
the bus driver was like yeah you're not
supposed to [ __ ] on this bus and i'm
like
he's like i just took my second [ __ ]
the guy was so pissed can you [ __ ] on
your bus gabriel
uh you know what that's always been the
rule is uh you're not supposed to bring
it on the bus
uh but my bus has two bathrooms my bus
has one in the front
and then there's one uh private one just
for me in the back
and uh now if i gotta go i gotta go and
i and and i says hey
is you know does the same rules apply
well the bus
the the bathroom in the front of the bus
is one of those you step on the pedal
yeah and it just
the hole and then whereas my toilet in
the back
actually flushes it legit fills up and
flushes
and it's it's like a regular toilet so
uh yeah i bring it all the time
when i can i'd rather go on the bus than
uh then go in some of these venues
that are just nasty yeah yeah how many
people are you traveling with
oh that's a good number what is that
what i i'm doing the beautiful mine
numbers right now yeah
exactly uh i got the numbers in it's
apparently 48. holy [ __ ] 48 people
yeah uh it's it's yeah it's a carnival
how many tour how many tour buses is
that
uh three three two three tour buses and
three tour buses and five
rigs what's everybody doing to basically
travel with a special so when people
come out to see the shows
i mean the stage is huge you know if
you're gonna perform
at a big arena 15 000 plus
it's got a it you can't just show up
with a stage and a a
a stool and a mic you got to you know
you got to give them bang for the buck
so
we got giant screens the stage is all
built it looks
like we're going to tape a special every
single night it looks like we're gonna
take the special
oh i love it dude this is so [ __ ]
badass
it's like wwe meets the food network
[Laughter]
are you slinging a lot of merch at your
shows
yes oh and so back to the merchandise
early on
my manager at the time was like listen
you go ahead and you peddle your
your little cds or whatever i don't want
any of your merch
i just want to work on your shows and
this and that the merch is separate you
keep all your all your merch which was
probably the biggest mistake
because the merch revenue now is is
through the roof and uh
yeah uh it's mine
except that like if the theater takes
like um 20
uh commission on your merch even when
they don't [ __ ] sell it that just
drives me nuts
what does the arena do about merch the
arena has their splits so for example
uh like soft goods they'll say oh it's
like a um
70 70 what is it it's 90 10 and then uh
like if it's cd or dvd or something like
that sometimes it's a little bit higher
but it's not much more yeah but uh
arenas they always have their own people
whereas theaters leaders they just take
the money but you sell it
to collect like the mob yeah wow
[ __ ] [ __ ] so uh so
how long have you been buddies with
snoop oh my god
so uh you know i'm not gonna claim to be
like oh we're homies we hang out all the
time
uh we know each other he's been super
nice to me every time we've we've had
the opportunity to be around one another
he invited me on his show he got me
annihilated
my life missing because of snow my son
told me that we wound up at sizzler
after that i don't remember
and i always remember when we go to
sizzler
i saw him a year after the uh that
podcast i did and we just kind of looked
at each other and i go you know what you
did to me right
and he's like hell yeah
so you know if we see each other we say
hi but uh you know we're not we're not
kicking out on the weekends
and you're both from long beach right
you're from long beach as well yes but i
stayed
yeah i think he moved to a few different
places
i think he lives in i want to say if
that's
i don't want to be out of line saying
where he lives yeah what's his address
but would you would you ever leave
california a lot of people are kind of
moving out of california or just moving
around or are you long beach
for life you know what i i keep having
this conversation more and more and this
was even before joe rogan uh took up you
know took his whole thing and
and took off and i understand joe rogan
leaving i completely understand
you you're about to sign a 100 million
dollar deal and california is going to
take 10 percent of that
for just doing nothing i'm out i would i
don't care where you're gonna sit you're
not taking 10 million away from me so
that made total sense
um from my end it was more so like
well where are we going to have more
freedom where are we going to be able to
just
feel like we can go out and do whatever
california is so strict
and that's the main thing it's like i
keep hearing people going to texas and
going to
atlanta not only for the tax breaks but
just for the space and just being able
to do what they want to do
a lot of production companies uh going
to atlanta
um you know film movies are still going
to happen but uh you know that's what
people are taking off
i keep having a conversation it's uh the
conversation was either
go to vegas go to texas go to atlanta
yeah i've been looking at vegas but i'm
not sure it's
it's a far commute because we still work
out of california you know
i was thinking about atlanta man
atlanta's pretty [ __ ] cool man
it's a big city so it's like one of
those you know it's almost like moving
to houston it's
you you almost feel like you're in an la
environment but you're getting a huge
break on your taxes and
the traffic isn't as ridiculous once you
get outside into the suburbs
right plus you get like 80
times the amount of house yes
oh my god my my friend who lives in
atlanta
uh he showed me his mansion that he
bought
that cost less than my house here in la
and uh he has a 12 a 12 bedroom
it's a mansion it's a 12 bedroom if you
have an elevator in your [ __ ] it's a
mansion yeah
and it's just enormous and i paid more
for my
house that's one level i know and then
now
it's like the house that we paid so much
[ __ ] money for
it's gonna burn down
i'm just waiting for the day when my
house burns down
it's fire i'm right in the middle of the
[ __ ] hollywood hills dude
like i like it's just
the kindling is all just around me it
smells like a fire pit outside
yeah is it smoky in long beach right now
you know what all the cars are covered
with ash
and then everybody has that
for sure uh so yeah we're feeling it but
i don't see flames so
uh yeah it's like that stunt you pulled
where you walked on that pole and
the fires out all around you
oh dude man i i appreciate you knowing
about my stuff
dude oh man i've been following you
forever
so you know if somebody doesn't know you
wants to be on your show they're just
doing it to
to sell [ __ ] i'm a huge fan of yours and
by the way that's
a sick crew t-shirt yeah man thank you
let me show you something let me see if
i can tilt it you see my little
refrigerator my little uh
a motley crew marshall uh refrigerator
so
killer dude uh is that a keurig machine
back there
yes we're thinking about coming out with
some coffee pretty soon
hey we're all just trying to come up
with a new hustle
what's sauce i'm like man really i got
to be that mexican
oh dude yeah yeah we got we got to send
you some hot sauce man
oh for sure i i am such a fan of my own
brand of hot sauce
that when the mexican border shut down
and we couldn't get any more of it
like i was just upset for myself it's
panicking i didn't even give a [ __ ]
about we couldn't sell it man i was like
dude i gotta go [ __ ] use some other
hot sauce [ __ ]
i feel like you're the biggest consumer
like or we are yeah we have to start
selling gallons of this [ __ ] stop
getting high on your own supply
cutting into the profits over here no
kidding have you tried any of these
drive-in movie theater shows
you know what my hat's off to any comic
that can pull those off but i'm way too
spoiled and i need i need 100
attention in the room uh or at least 90
percent
i i i can't handle not being able to
hear the people
and if people are honking the horns or
they're using wipers or they're flicking
lights that
that's that's like a hell gig times 10
and it is
really worth it to go out there and give
people a half-assed show because then i
feel like it would only be for the money
right i agree 100 man i i couldn't agree
more
and then i found out that they're
charging like
250 bucks per car
what they are dude like if you want to
go see one of these comedy shows at the
drive-in you got to pay 250 bucks for
the car
wow you can pack the car with as many
people as you want
but i mean [ __ ] yeah and everybody has
the rules
uh you know some say you can sit outside
the car bring launchers and sit outside
the car
some people are like you can't do that
and then of course you know how is the
sound
what's it are you gonna is it gonna be
one of those where you hook up a speaker
to your
to your window like old school days is
it gonna be you gotta
set your radio to a certain station and
try to get it that way
uh uh there's just too many uh you know
i i do fairs
and fair just doing a fair you're
outside and so you got to deal with the
weather
you got to deal with bugs you got to
deal with helicopters and planes and
motorcycles revving it in the parking
lot and so there's so many potential
distractions
and you're just you're asking for it um
again if you pull it off there's been a
few comics that have like
bert kreicher man hey my hat's off to
him and his crew
they're out there grinding it they're
out there doing it making it happen but
i i just i can't do it i just can't i'm
not
anti-chafing cream yeah where can we get
that
fluffyguy.com hey where's the cream at
oh my god let's plug that [ __ ] right now
go ahead and get go ahead and give us
your pitch this is the below deck
right here below deck by uh by allspice
and basically this is the powder spray
you spray it where uh
where the sun don't shine and you keep
yourself extra fresh and
anti-moist and here's the chafing one so
you take that one off and
it's like deodorant you you bring out
the little happy stuff and then you uh
you apply uh and um yeah your life is
better for it so
so you put that like up your butt crack
on your ball sack
the the the it's a ball stack stick
yeah you don't have to like sit there
and constantly spread your leg out
oh man all right dude what else do we
got let's not let's not keep
i'm actually curious about how you got
started in comedy you've been in it for
so long
uh and now you're just killing it but
where did you start in la
uh yes uh long beach california to be
exact um
i grew up here and it was one of those
things where i knew that i needed to
live in either la or new york
to get into comedy uh at the time you
know there was no social media
it was just one of those things where i
just knew this is where i had to be
and my mom moved to san diego and she
said hey let's go to san diego and i'm
like i gotta stay here in
l.a and this is right when i turned 18.
and so i you know i wound up living on
different couches until i got into the
mean
but uh yeah i started at the age of uh
20 is when i
first hit the stage and called myself a
comment how old were you when you did
last comic standing
let me see i was probably five years
into the game when i did that
and and they kicked you off right well i
snuck in a blackberry that goes to show
right there i had a blackberry cell
phone
uh those were the those were the [ __ ]
back then the blackberry
and i snuck it in to stay in touch with
my girl and they caught me
texting her it wasn't like some people
said oh well he's probably getting jokes
from the outside i'm like really i'm
like i came into the show
already being like that guy that was
considered the uh
the the ringer on the show and i'm like
i was just trying to stay in touch
making sure somebody else wasn't with
her
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's why i brought the phone uh yes i
got caught and i got kicked off the show
i told people that i made history
being the first mexican ever deported
off nbc
yeah [ __ ] man it worked out you know i
don't
anybody who won the show the very few
people actually
made a big career out of winning the
show it's usually the people that
came in second or third or got kicked
off early that
went on to do something right getting
kicked off or smuggling in a cell phone
is a better story
i think you probably got more people
aware of that than uh
a lot of the people who want it and then
you're known for
like you do these hilarious voices and
like you're on stage persona were you
always doing like funny voices and stuff
like that
like growing up and stuff yeah that was
the only thing i
had a little gift for was being able to
do that so like when i was
sold i entered a school talent show and
i was doing impressions of like
ronald reagan and pee-wee herman and
mickey mouse
and you know for a 10 year old doing
anything is a big deal but doing voices
like that that was a
that was cutting edge for the time and
so i just
i noticed that uh telling jokes was one
thing but being able to tell stories and
animate them
now you know you you were able to just
get so much oh shoot sorry
my dogs are like stop moving your hands
what do you think and they bark
um but yeah i noticed if you animate the
stories you were just
get such a bigger audience yeah that's
crazy
i did the the voiceover you did with uh
nickelodeon and telling the joke about
the girl
you sounded exactly like a chick no
offense i was like [ __ ] this guy's good
eerie huh oh my god yes like right now
with the all that ash in the parking lot
uh
yeah yeah what a great transition voice
over work huh it's it's
it seems like it's a lot it's more laid
back than anything else that somebody
can do right i mean
stand up is number one doing voice over
work is
is definitely a close second because
it's like they make you feel so
you know you don't gotta memorize stuff
you show up there's a director there
they work with you
can you go high can you go low can you
you know they they tell you exactly how
to do the voices and they feed you
and you know you take breaks and it's
nice you'll knock out a whole movie in
four sessions
that's crazy that's crazy what was your
first voice acting gig
oh i did a um a cartoon for disney
called
emperor's new school yeah and i played
twins i played uh characters named you
and two
and uh yeah that's that i i don't even
think i watched the episodes but i
remember the characters there was two
skinny characters
flew into it yeah and anytime i've
worked with disney with exception of the
last movie i played twins
so like when i was when i did that i
played twins i did uh planes
disney's planes and i played two wins on
the
on that movie as well they're just
trying to get more out of me
freaking disney that's funny when i was
nine years old my uncle was an artist
for disney
and uh he had me i was like the perfect
size for aladdin
so there's a magic carpet ride aladdin
at the orlando disney world
and that's my body as a nine-year-old
boy is they
they sketched out aladdin on a carpet
and
way yeah and i never made any money off
it and
you're aladdin you're in the room i'm
aladdin in disney uh orlando
uh voiceover voiceover seems like
a really good uh thing for coronavirus
right like yeah you could do it from
home if you had to i did i did uh i'm
gonna be in the new um
space jam movie with lebron and so i
played character
and i recorded it here uh here at my
office wow
is there anything you can tell us about
the new space jam movie
it's not the same story as the michael
jordan one
it's you know you would think oh is it
just going to be the exact same thing
it's
it's a completely different story and
it's not even um
i wouldn't even call it a sequel because
it's not like uh oh here's the next
evolution of it it's just it's a whole
different version of space jam
are there aliens um i can't say exactly
what
what the uh what what the opposing team
is but uh you you know it's
it's in the vein but it's just it's a
different story okay cool
different story and uh yeah it's there's
a nice twist on this one too
wait if you had to guess how long until
that [ __ ]
bus gets wrapped up in in tennessee and
and
you got shows going again i keep hearing
april
2021 that's what they're hoping for
but you know i mean when this whole
thing popped off they said oh just
a couple weeks just stay home for a
couple weeks and then we'll go back to
our lives and i'm like this is no
um i hope april is realistic
everybody keeps thinking that as soon as
it turns 20 21 that all of this shit's
gonna go away and we're gonna go back to
normal but
this is gonna go for a minute um
i honestly i couldn't say if you know if
that is the case but
that they're hoping for it they've all
the tickets everything is set up for
april 2021.
i mean it's great you think april 2021
like comedy clubs will be open by then
but like that's 350 people
like a [ __ ] arena's like
opening up 4 000 person venues just
seems like it's going to be a lot more
pain in the ass to do that
that's going to take a while and what i
noticed this past week is that
they started allowing um 20 capacity
at some of these restaurants here and uh
here locally like i know in orange
county
uh 20 percent now is allowed inside the
restaurant for dining
so if they can up it and up it up but
slowly just to see what's going to
happen
um i i'm not above going and performing
inside of a restaurant if they allow
little stages and you can have a you
know 30 40 people in there that's enough
for a show
yeah red lobster man dave and busters
dude biscuits there you go
hell yeah man well i i have a friend of
mine who owns a restaurant and he did
the whole patio thing
where they brought the inside outside
and then they put bistro lights and they
made it look really cool
and uh i asked him i said hey well you
know do you have live entertainment
it's outside and he goes the city
forbids any type of
he goes we can't even have a dj i'm like
oh shoot it's that serious and they're
like yeah there's no they don't want
people hanging out
that's and i'm like okay i get it but if
they're gonna allow dine in what's the
problem now
i mean it's crazy now because
everything's outside dining and now
there's [ __ ] ash everywhere and fires
it's like who wants to sit outside and
breathe that [ __ ] it's like a smoking
section
yeah everything is very hypocritical oh
you know one day it's this one day it's
that
and uh i i just want life to go back to
normal but until then
if you need anti-chafing
i love it man yeah i can't thank you
enough gabe i
really do appreciate you and uh you know
i don't know what else to say dude like
i really thank you for your time man
yeah man and i'll be happy to accept
some of that hot sauce and uh take a
picture with it
just uh you know before i eat it so if
you got any
uh early stuff man you know my buddy
will tell you how many exes i am
dude it's uh it's it's headed your way
brother it's headed your way
everybody fluffyguy.com is that right
yes sir fluffyguy.com buy some gabriel
iglesias merch
dude you're the man thank you so much
brother thanks gabriel
i don't know about you but i absolutely
fell in love with gabriel iglesias
during that podcast you know what else
he made me
want to just tighten up my operation to
be
more productive more efficient
and i'll tell you one thing that i want
to do
to become more productive and efficient
is to start
a wild ride clips page
and i gotta say some but maybe one of
you listening right now
actually did so except did it in a way
that sucks because it's got these videos
on there that
nobody from jackass wants on there and
i personally emailed the person
responsible for the
stevo's wild ride clips page and asked
them to take it down
and they didn't so a big fat [ __ ] you to
whoever
you are okay and
you know [ __ ] it we're gonna make our
own clips page so stay tuned for that
and street team i love you yeah